[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Abigail
is with us in Charleston South Carolina
hi Abigail how are
you I'm all right how are you better
than we deserve what's
up um well it's a bit of a financial
question as well as a relational
question um I uh my husband and I got uh
married three years ago we've been
renting for quite a bit and then um uh
we went up near family and they uh they
offered to sell us a house well my
mother-in-law is very controlling which
is the relational part of the question
um
she she
controls everything and has the
codependency issues where she will go
and she will buy something for you even
though you're going to buy yourself and
you didn't want her to buy it or for
instance the house that they were trying
to sell us so she bought it now we're
working on it which is abely me stop a
minut did you guys buy this house or not
we were going to okay so you've not
you've not bought the
house no we haven't she has okay so
you're not getting that house what are
you going to
do well right now we're working on it
and why are you working on her
house um because we're supposed to be
buying it from her so you agreed to buy
it
later yeah is this in writing or is it
just a handshake
agreement it's a handshake agreement
really okay when you buy it from her
what does that look like you proba you
go get a mortgage and you purchase the
house and then you're the owner
right yeah and from what I was like what
I was wanting to do was I was trying to
get my husband to agree to get a a
mortgage and then some on top of that to
do repairs well we need a contractor for
that and my husband's bucking and
kicking to to not get a contractor
because he's supposed to get his
contractor's license soon and he doesn't
want to put his further in debt what
does what does that have to do with your
mother-in-law I don't know how
to approach her um why does she need to
be
approached well because we're living
with her right now oh or she's living
with us we're both living with her
mother what um and she has her own home
she just refused to go
home what do you guys
make um my husband started a new job in
June doing hbac and right now it's
about uh it's up to 2,000 every two
weeks so 4,000 a
month and and how old are you guys
uh he's 30 and I'm 23 okay we've got uh
two kids okay and you're staying home
with the kids it it yeah sounds like the
first order of business to uh create
some reasonable relational boundaries is
to create some physical separation and
you guys need to go you guys need to go
get an apartment
tomorrow that's what I'm I'm I was
thinking yeah but I don't know how to
talk my husband into that well then you
don't have a mother-in-law problem you
have a husband
problem maybe the maybe the Mommy's boy
needs to take care of his family instead
of his mommy's
wishes she got three sons she does this
to all of them I'm sorry and she has
three sons and she does this to all oh
she didn't do anything she didn't do
anything to him that they didn't let
happen I don't think she's I don't think
she's the problem I think your husband
is any any boundary you try to set it
immediately devolves into
yelling move
out move out tell your husband I'm
leaving I hope you come
too me and the kids are getting an
apartment this is untenable if she
chooses to end the relationship over
this that's on her it's not on
you but this isn't not a relationship
anyways to begin with this is not your
mother-in-law's fault this is your
husband's fault and your fault you
agreed to move move in with her and you
knew this before you moved in with
her yeah I thought she'd go home no you
didn't didn't no you
didn't you knew this you knew exactly
what you were dealing with and you chose
to ignore it trying to make a financial
deal we're trying to save $2 and in the
middle of it we're putting up with the
Wicked Witch of the
West yeah to save
$2 you guys need to go have a life you
and your husband go build a life and you
can love her she's a lot easier to love
from a
distance you got that right yeah she
needs some
distance but she's not the problem you
and your husband are the problem you've
you've you guys just stepped up into a
bear trap and then you're bitching about
bear
traps
yeah yeah play this out you get an
apartment she's mad I don't I don't even
care about her that's it I mean she's
she's not relevant in the discussion you
guys need to decide we are going to do
things that are smart relationally and
smart for our future and not put
ourselves in untenable toxic situations
to save $2 whether it's working on the
house without a contractor's license or
buying a house from this woman who's
controlling why you enter into a deal
why you go along with entering into a
deal with this woman to buy a house from
her is beyond me these are people that
are best kept at arms length not right
up close you know this now you're only
23 so I shouldn't fuss at you but you
know you call me and you're all torqued
out about her and I'm telling you you
and your husband can solve
this yeah but she's still mothering him
and he likes
it yeah yeah she pays for just about
everything well quit taking her money
I'm not taking your money anymore and
you're not controlling my life anymore
you don't have to be mean about it but
just be kind and just go listen you know
we've made some mistakes by setting up
our relationship with you early in our
marriage and we're going to have to
change that so here's the thing we're
going to have a little physical
separation a financial separation and a
real estate separation from you so Mom
you need to get that house on the market
and get it sold we're not buying it
we're going to go rent an apartment and
we're going to save up some money and
get us a
house yeah it's completely clean and
she's not going to like it but I'm not
taking a poll here she doesn't get a
vote the problem is you all gave her a
vote yeah again you don't have to be
unkind you just be very firm and just
say it and if it devolves into yelling
that's on her but I don't put up with
people yelling that's
ridiculous yeah I mean what husband is
going to let his 23y old wife get yelled
at come on man
tell him to run down Walmart and pick up
a backbone they're on aisle
three Abigail this is G not GNA be fun
and what's gonna happen when you say all
this to him if he watched this call back
what would his response
be would it be they don't understand
like it's not like that she doesn't give
me an allowance it's different is that
what it would be he arguing with the
recording saying
well I we we shouldn't get an apartment
CU we're getting it from my uncle and
what's he going to think stop taking
things from your family they strings
attached and it doesn't end
well yeah start your own life what I
always say don't back out of this deal
stop taking allowance and if you all
need to go make more money then go do
that the financial inscest in this is
unbelievable I know yeah I mean really I
don't know what to do you know well I I
what you do is you have a marriage
problem you and your HB husband need to
separate from these people far enough
that they don't have any Apron Strings
or wallet strings controlling you get an
apartment there's apartments in
Charleston South Carolina nice ones go
get you an apartment and go get you go
get a job he go Gets a Job whatever we
got to do to make it on our way we're a
young married couple we don't have any
money we're trying to get started but
you don't have to live under the thumb
of the control of these toxic human
beings it really it needs to stop you
asked hun that's what I'm telling you
but really you can't blame her anymore
after
today if you if you want to blame
somebody get you a mirror it's your
fault after today those are also at
Walmart yeah Ila 4 yeah they're right
over next to the backbone aisle the
mirror aisle yeah and you guys you guys
got to make some decisions here mama
don't get to control you unless you
allow her to you're like grown people
and stuff this is the Ramsey Show